federal reserve is pushing ahead with a
study on whether to implement its own
digital currency and they're going to
release the paper shortly uh according
to jerome powell uh establishing the
digital dollar has been on the fed's
radar for more than a year uh announced
in may it's launching a deeper
examination and uh jerome powell
recently said that the test for cbdc is
quote are there clear and tangible
benefits that outweigh any cost and risk
which
i think is a pretty fair way to evaluate
it okay we have we understand central
bank digital currencies for those that
don't know what that is it's essentially
a digital token so if you think dollars
used to be in physical form pieces of
paper
uh we then moved to today uh when you go
to the atm or you look on uh your bank
account uh online uh dollars are not in
paper form it's not like the bank's just
got literally trillions of dollars
sitting there instead what they have is
they have electronic q-sips that are in
centralized databases so inside of
jpmorgan they kind of keep track of all
the different things inside of bank of
america they keep track of it all on a
centralized uh ledger inside their
business inside of uh you know wells
fargo or first republic or whatever then
when these banks want to actually
transact with each other what they are
doing is not actually sending
the dollars around what they're actually
doing is they are simply just settling
their books with each other which is a
little bit different so a little nuance
in terms of how that works but it's
called electronic q-sip c-u-s-i-p
and it's basically a file format that
uses inside these centralized databases
now what they're talking about the
central bank digital currency is
evolving or improving that technology to
go from electronic q-sips to digital
tokens
it's still a dollar it's still the same
monetary policy nothing changes it's
just a technology change um and so if
you're evaluating creating a certain
type of technology if you say hey are
there clear and tangible benefits that
outweigh any costs and risk i think
that's a pretty good way to evaluate it
now boston fed is undertaking a
multi-year research with the mit to
explore the technology that could be
used for the cbdc and the first phase of
the research is expected soon uh there's
a whole bunch of other countries who
have been playing around in this
trying to figure it out
we have a quote i think from jerome
powell uh that is uh uh i think a pretty
you know rational thought process here
he says we think it's really important
that central bank maintain a stable
currency and payment systems for the
public's benefit that's one of our jobs
completely agree right i think he he
nailed it here um and so obviously you
wouldn't want to introduce a central
bank digital currency if you weren't
gonna uh have a stable payment system or
something like that uh if you thought
you could make it more stable or more
dependable then you absolutely would
want to uh to introduce it
and when you look at we've got a map
on a number of these countries
this map shows what other countries are
doing so about five countries around the
world have launched central bank digital
currencies even if they're on a small
scale there's 14 pilots 16 of them have
developed them
32 are researching them 10 started it
but now are inactive and then two
cancelled uh their plans for central
bank digital currency so kind of all
over the map shout out to atlantic
council for that uh for that map right
there but yeah look the us is almost
falling behind on this and i understand
drone power kind of went back and forth
with
should we be more aggressive about this
or do we want to sit back see what
happens study it a little bit more and
make sure we do it right
uh i agree that it's more important to
do it right than do it first right so
other countries have already launched
this we've seen this in japan in the uk
all these other places but we are
falling behind um
the four largest central banks the
federal reserve european central bank
bank of japan and bank of england the us
is the furthest behind on the research
and the uh deployment of a central bank
digital currency
we got to hurry up i see i see a couple
of people asking about uh why they were
canceled why people started doing it and
then canceled it i'm not sure we can
actually research why they uh why they
ended up canceling it but um
two of them did and then the other piece
of this too i think is really
interesting uh so my personal opinion is
that every single fiat currency is going
to end up being digitized right so we'll
have a digital dollar digital one
digital euro digital yen digital peso et
cetera
and
it's less about changing the monetary
policy it's less about changing the
natural structure of the currency it's
much much more about
changing the technology and so if i said
to you hey uh your currency is
susceptible to hours of operation you
have to have if you want to send large
amounts a wire you have to call in by
certain time every day then it's going
to take a day to settle uh maybe two
days depending where you're sending it
the fee structure et cetera if all of a
sudden i can put that in a much more
advantageous position say you still have
dollars but you're able to send it
instantaneously cheaper you have access
24 7 365 uh and the settlement time is
uh is much
faster then i think most people say hey
look i would love to uh to go ahead and
do that um it's just going to take some
time i think for people to kind of wrap
their heads around it the other question
that comes is how are they going to
build the technology is the federal
reserve do they have the technical uh
capabilities and appetite right going
and building this is pretty difficult so
do they have the capabilities and the
appetite to build it or will they simply
partner with a private company or or
some sort of technology provider whether
it is to build internally a brand new
cbdc uh or would they just somehow kind
of partner with one of the existing
stablecoin uh providers and say hey look
we're going to go ahead and we're going
to use this we're going to you know
choose you as the as the player here
yeah i agree this technology is very new
right so in may 2020 about 35 countries
were kind of exploring it uh and think
about deploying it and all that now 81
countries that represent over 90 of the
global global gdp have
gotten their gotten their feet wet right
in this situation um but i think i'm
curious your thoughts i think actually
developing these currencies will do
more control for the government and less
privacy for the actual individuals i
completely agree that's the downside in
my opinion is control uh right now let's
say that i want to see what's in your
bank account uh and i'm the government i
have to go i have to get like a fisa
court or some sort of order either
freeze your assets look at them so they
say well yeah
uh but in terms of the um
uh stable coins they'd be able to see
everything and on top of that the other
piece of it uh ends up being that
there's a um
a really uh
uh big issue around the privacy and the
financial surveillance so what happens
if all of a sudden the rails say hey
john uh you drink too much coffee today
you can't buy that soda you gotta buy
water
okay that's like pretty aggressive
extreme you know example what if all of
a sudden they say hey john uh actually
you know what you can't ride the uh uh
bus today you gotta walk
you even walked enough well someone said
something relative like this in the chat
is what if they start deciding who you
are allowed and not allowed to do
business with
it's possible again i'm not i'm not
saying that they're going to go do that
right away but the fact that they have
the ability you can just see like it it
it is an incentive to kind of continue
to creep into those worlds uh and that's
scary stuff right do you think we create
a uh central bank digital currency
within the next five years
i think that there
will be a mass global adoption of stable
coins within
the next you know three years already
you could argue that people are starting
to adopt it now um the question is going
to be does the united states create an
official uh fed coin right or central
bank digital currency i think they will
end up creating one
five years uh i think they will have
decided to do it they'll say yes we're
gonna do this the big question is how
are they technically gonna do it can
they build it themselves i don't know if
they can get it built and launched in a
you know three to five year period uh
but if they went they just partnered
with somebody who already built it then
it's possible so so i think that the
obstacle is less about the decision to
go ahead and do this i think the
obstacle is more about the technical uh
kind of execution and actually getting
it to the point where remember you not
only have to serve the 330 million
americans you know uh that use the
dollar as their uh
reserve currency get paid in it saving
it et cetera but it's the global reserve
currency so you have to be able to use
the dollar globally with all sorts of
different technical complexities that
are added so it look it's a very very
difficult technical problem um that i
just don't think they could create in
you know six months what's up guys bang
bang a bunch of you want to bring that
trillionaire energy every day and if you
want to do it in your financial life go
use sofi sofi's our exclusive sponsor
because we think they've got a great
piece of software that'll help you
accomplish your financial dreams go to
sofi.com today to get started you can
invest in everything from etfs to
individual stocks to cryptocurrencies to
ipos and they even have an automated and
best function head on over to sofi.com
pomp today and make sure you come back
tomorrow to watch more of the best
business show
[Music]
you